premièreportage de Marie-Eve Bé.
- Il est devenu roia mère.a mèr.
Mais cette cérémonie, quin'avais
70 ans, est venu ajouter
un peu de fanfare et de décorum
du Royaume-Uni. Charles III
n'était pas présent au moment
où ces paroles ont d'abord été
prononcées, en présence
de membres de la famille royale
ministres toujours en vie.
Le roi a profité de la cérémonie
pour rendre un hommage bien
senti à sa mère, Élisabeth II.
Mais c'était surtout le mome
responsabilités publiquement
pour la première
"Je suis profondément conscient
de ce grand héritage,
des devoirs et des la
souveraineté, qui me sont
désormai",
a dit le roi.
Dans la cour extérieure du
Palais ds de membres du public
ont pu se tailler une place pour
à une page d'histoire.
(coup de feu)
Gavin Skerritt était
Palais de St-James, plusieurs
centaines de membres du public
ont pu se tailler une place pour
(coup de feu) feu) feu)
Gavin Sk
aux premières loges.
ne chose que le titre
soit automatiquement remis
qui est importante. Et j'adore
les cérémonies. C'était quelque
chose d'être témoin de ça,
À 19
aussi attaché à la monarchie,
'elle représente
et à ses rituels.sûr plus
importants par le passé,
avant les réseaux sociaux
et que tout le monde ne sachetas
voir encore aujourd'hui c'est
important pour notre héritage et
pour maintenir en vie les idées)
Il fallait jouer du coude
pour ent
qui est ensuite rentré,
en voiture, au Palais de
Buckingham, à quelques centaine.
Sarah Gray a même réussi à se
faire une photo, un peu floue,
mais qui fait tout
"Nous avons vu le roi
Il saluait, dit-elle. Nous avons
attendu environ deux heures
et demie mais ça valait le coup.
Quel souvenir!"
C'est maintenant aux autres pays
du royaume de se retrouverrles .
Le roi doit se rendre au cours
des prochains jours en Irlande
du Nord, au pays de Galle
et en Écosse avant de rev
des cérémonies funéraires.
L'accès aux grilles du palais
en après-midi, pour la plus
grande déception de tous ceux
qui continuent, bouquets en
sympathies à la famille royale.
Bousculades, escalades, leurs
tentatives ont été vaines.rz,
rédige calmement une note qu'il
veut laisser pour la reine.
Difficile pour lui de trouveroue
sa reconnaissance pour cepour ce
qu'il conçoit comme une vie de
"J'ai attendu au dernier momente
mes fleurs et j'écris
encore. C'est difficilede lui et
ma gratitude."
C'est finalement aux motsde Shae
adieu à la reine.Les dernières a
pièce sont d'un des survivants,
dit-il. "Il nous faut subir le
fardeau de cette triste époque;
dire ce que nous ressentons, et
non ce que nous devrions dire.
Les plus vieux ont le plus
souffert. Nous qui. Nous qui. Ns
jeunes, nous ne verrons jamais
tant de
jamais si longtemps."
ssi Shakespeare